[BLANK_AUDIO]
What are you doing there, RJ?
>> I'm geocaching.
It's like a treasure hunt, except that
we use lat longs instead of an x.
>> Wow, that sounds awesome.
Sounds like you're using
lots of geoconcepts.
Let's take the time to
talk about geocoding and
other location web services instead.
>> GeoGreat.
Geocoding is one of the many
location services available via
the Google Maps APIs.
For the next few lessons,
we'll demonstrate using these services.
It's important to note that, most of
these services can be used either on
the service side, for example, as part
of a process you run in a script, or
client side as part of
a user facing code.
The functionality is likely
the same in each service, but
obviously the syntax
is a little different.
And there are different
reasons to use them.
>> The server side option is ideal,
when you already have
data that you need to do a bunch of
stuff with, with no user input needed.
Like a list of 100 points for
which you need to get information,
such as the address, the coordinate,
the time zone, or nearby schools.
When you make a web service
request in this way,
results can be returned in
either JSON or XML format.
>> But sometimes you may
not have data in advance.
The addresses, user location, or
other requests come in dynamically
as part of the user input.
Maybe a user clicks on a map to
indicate his or her current location.
And wants to find movie theaters nearby.
These type of situations are ideal for
client side services.
>> As we go into this in more detail,
keep in mind that we structure all the
web services requests in the same way.
We put in their required parameters and
we get back a textual response.
Let's start out by explaining
the Geocoding Service via an http
request in our browser.